du coup
la liberté enfin pour marcel fontaine
jean paul kauffmann et marcel carton les
otages français au liban libéré hier
soir sont arrivés ce matin à paris
bonsoir oublier l'image figée des otages
que nous vous présentions depuis plus de
mille jours déjà voici l'autre images
chargées de joie d'émotion trois hommes
qui descendent d'un falcon 50 sur
l'aéroport de villacoublay dans la
région parisienne
marcel carton marcel fontaine et jean
paul kauffmann sont libres depuis hier
soir 19h30 la rédaction d'antenne 2 a
décidé de leur consacrer un journal
exceptionnel ce soir place aux
témoignages aux analyses
nous sommes ensemble jusqu'à 21h autour
de nous sur le plateau d'antenne de
madame joëlle kauffmann qui a accepté
fort gentiment notre invitation
elle est entourée de cinq hommes qui ont
connu le même cauchemar que son mari
avec eux dont roger eau qui est à mes
côtés
les autres vont arriver dans quelques
instants avec eux tranquillement pendant
une heure nous allons essayer de
comprendre avant d'aller plus loin
arrêtons nous quelques minutes sur une
autre image forte de l'actualité l'image
synonyme elle aussi d'otages et de
libération la nuit dernière sur l'île
d'ouvéa en nouvelle-calédonie les 23
personnes qui étaient détenus en otages
ont elles aussi étaient libérés contexte
différent vous le savez car sur place en
nouvelle calédonie les forces de l'ordre
ont lancé un assaut contre les preneurs
d'otages le bilan est très lourd
17 morts quinze militants
indépendantistes et deux militaires
l'opération a débuté à 6h15 heure locale
mais les 300 représentants des forces de
l'ordre qui ont donné l'assaut à la
grotte réputée imprenable non délivrer
les otages qu après 8 heures d'efforts
au cours d'une conférence de presse
donnée au commissariat à nouméa
bernard pons a détaillé le déroulement
des événements indiquant que de revolver
de gros calibre et des clés de menottes
avaient été fournies aux captifs leur
permettant ainsi de participer à la
fusillade depuis l'intérieur de la
grotte
l'effet de surprise n'a pas joué tout à
fait les ravisseurs au nombre d'une
trentaine était parfaitement organisé
je savais que ce serait une opération
difficile parce que je crois que c'est
une prise d'otage qui fait date cela
prend de l'âge généralement se trouve
face à deux ou trois ravisseurs armés
d'un mauvais pistolet là on avait une
véritable
bandes armées donc je savais que c'était
une opération difficile et je voulais
prendre toutes les précautions prendre
mon temps pour la préparer et si l'on
n'avait pu obtenir que les ravisseurs
rendent danse otages sans attaquer le
site
j'aurais été ravi malheureusement ça n'a
pas été possible
en dépit de ces événements est du lourd
bilan de l'opération le calme règne
maintenant en nouvelle calédonie mais le
fln ks dénonce l'intervention militaire
i want payez when he et ses amis parle
de gâchis de morts inutiles qui seront
vengés
oui nous évoquerons plus longuement la
situation en nouvelle-calédonie tout à
l'heure dans la deuxième partie la
partie réflexion du journal en attendant
revenons à la libération des trois
derniers otages français au liban
les images se bousculent dans nos têtes
et dans nos esprits nous sommes témoins
de grands moments de joie d'émotion
d'interrogation aussi nous y reviendrons
ce sont ces images que nous allons
privilégier dans un premier temps
ensuite nous essaierons de comprendre
pourquoi et comment on en est arrivé là
en toile de fond il y aura des
témoignages l'historique des
négociations nous évoquerons également
le rôle joué par certains états dans ce
genre d'affaires mais tout de suite
l'image symbole de cette journée celle
que nous avons enregistré ce matin sur
l'aéroport de villacoublay
les retrouvailles sont extrêmement
dignes fallait dire discrète
seuls les enfants ont laissé poindre
leur émotion philippe gassot à son
arrivée jean paul kauffmann à une
hésitation une fraction de seconde il ne
reconnaît pas son fils grégoire et trois
ans c'est une éternité pour un enfant
quand son père est parti en reportage au
liban il avait 11 ans aujourd'hui il en
a 14 les retrouvailles ont été très
digne presque trop comme si des amis se
retrouvaient après une longue absence la
gêne peut-être d'avoir changé pays et de
n'avoir plus qu'un passé lointain en
commun
seuls les enfants qui ont pendant trois
ans
rêver les retrouvailles l'espace et leur
trop plein de chagrin ce sont trois
années de l'armée d'angoua ce qui passe
la bombe
il va falloir du temps pour se
reconnaître mais c'est fait les familles
sont à nouveau réunis les journalistes
retrouvent un des leurs enlevés sur la
route de l'aéroport à beyrouth liban et
dans toutes les pensées ou il nous a dit
cela c'est un jour est formidable bien
sûr aujourd'hui mais
c'est quand même un jour kiki qui est
qui qui reste assombri par le fait que
nous ne sommes que trois et que moi j'ai
été enlevé le 22 mai 1985 avec un homme
qui s'appelait michel seurat j'étais
avec lui pendant de longs mois et puis
nous l'avons vu s'éteindre peu à peu et
j'ai une certaine manière j'ai un peu
honte aujourd'hui la d'être la fab on ne
jouons pas sur les mots mais c'est sa
demande et un marcel carton et marcel
fontaine on a vu michel seurat lutter
avec avec avec avec désespoir bien aussi
je dire avec avec avec noblesse l'aï il
s'exprimait pas beaucoup il se voyait
mourir il a voulu vivre ccc c'est
quelque chose de d'affreux et puis
aujourd'hui d'abord et avant tout ma
pensée va à marie sera sa femme je ne
sais pas où elle est actuellement mais
et à ses deux filles
et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
et paix avec désespoir il ya aussi
j'veux dire avec avec avec noblesse l'aï
il s'exprimait pas beaucoup il se voyait
mourir il a voulu vivre ccc c'est
quelque chose de d'affreux et puis
aujourd'hui d'abord et avant tout ma
pensée va à marie sera sa femme je ne
sais pas où elle est actuellement mais
et à ses deux filles
michel au début me disait tu sais moi
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal personnellement
au début les premières semaines furent
fut en furent affreuse
michel lui était tout à fait bon il
prenait la situation avec une certaine
philosophie les prenais des notes il
écrivait cetera
et puis enfin il disait moi tu sais je
suis prêt à attendre trois ans pour
revoir mes deux filles j'utilise a mis
trois ans mais je me suis fou tu te
rends compte trois ans et puis bon et
c'est lui qui a qui a disparu nous
l'avons vu pour la dernière fois le 28
décembre 1985 était n'arrivait plus à
tenir debout
il a été transféré dans un endroit côté
de nos tenues de nos cellules de notre
ces bulles et puis on l'a entendu
pendant encore quelques jours ils tous
effroyablement il avait enfin cccc c'est
quelque chose de terrible
on était tous les quatre ensemble
on va demander à marcel carton marcel
fontaine là ils l'ont vu quotidiennement
là et qui luttait puis il savait qu'il a
failli c'est parce qu'il avait
exactement mais ils savaient qu'ils
allaient que c'était quick c'était
désespère il aurait pu
et moi je prends fait il aurait pu
mourir auprès des siens et puis il est
il mort tout seul c'est quelque chose
d'affreux ça je ne peux pas l'oublier
oui nous étions chesnais depuis le mois
de février l'an dernier après les là
l'intervention familiale américaine
l'aller les bateaux là qui s'approchait
des côtes
ç'a eu pour résultat qu'on nous supprime
la radio premièrement et ensuite qu'on
nous pose des chaînes et puis bon on a
eu des mois j'ai eu les chaînes aux
pieds ainsi que mes compagnons depuis le
mois de février
l'an dernier on s'y habitue 1 on revient
pas de des camps de la mort il faut pas
exagérer non plus mais c'est ça a été on
en a survécu je soutiens publics
oui de nombreuses personnalités ont
partagé l'émotion des familles des
otages ce matin sur l'aéroport de
villacoublay
parmi elles madame danielle mitterrand
jacques chirac et charles pasqua
nous reviendrons d'ailleurs assez
longuement tout à l'heure sur les
déclarations du premier ministre dans
quelques instants à nos côté joëlle
kauffmann et et roger haut qu'on ne
présente plus madame kaufmann dans quel
état d'esprit étiez-vous ce matin on
vous a vu très sereine mais n'y avait
pas deux il n'y avait pas un
enthousiasme un forcené sur votre visage
ce matin je me trouve étrangement calme
ça fait trois ans qu'on attendait ces
moments là et on y croyait encore pas
c'était très très irréel j cru quand tu
entendu les paroles de jean paul
interview de roger quoi c'est l'heure je
me suis reconnu sa voix tout ça je me
suis chez lui c'est lui c'est lui
j'étais un peu inquiète pour les enfants
médusés très bouleversée comme vous
l'avez vu comme faisant du pull louey
c'est une belle image totalement
consentant mémoire des notions n'ai pas
pleuré pendant trois ans et comme si
toute les larmes des ces trois années de
l'angoissé de résulter d'un seul coup
alors c'est vrai on était un peu calme y
avait pas d exubérance et puis cette
arrivée était aussi beaucoup plus qu'un
incident avait été organisée de manière
plus calme pour eux c'est je crois que
c'était mieux ben quand l'un d'eux
comment avez vous trouvé votre marié
d'affaires solides et sereins
complètement il a peu changé
c'est un événement pour vous un pays
complètement je me disais comme dans
quel état vont s'aimer mais bon il est
revenu un petit peu commune thouarault
vie il parle énormément il vous avez vu
comme il était bon c'est vrai qu'il
parle trop c'est fâcheux des cèpes à son
habitude quelqu'un de très réservé et
très lui aussi c'est comme s'ils
sortaient trois ans de parole et de mai
moi j'ai tout vu formidable forcément
mais je savais qu'il serait candidat
mangez vous vous êtes libre depuis le 27
novembre un service à thé vous avez été
libéré en même temps que j'ai envie dans
bourdin et c'est vous qui avez réalisé
la première interview de des otages dans
l'avion notamment de notre confrère
jean-louis comment ça s'est passé ce
matin
bagua grâce à certaines informations
j'étais donc salonique et j'attendais
l'avion qui venait de beyrouth et
lorsque j'ai vu atterrir ce jet privé
venant de beyrouth sur l'aéroport de
salonique
j'étais vraiment très très ému je me
suis avancé vers l'avion j'ai été
autorisé à monter à bord et donc j'ai
j'ai découvert avec a vraiment avec
beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup de joie
les trois otages libérés ces trois ans
dont j'avais attendu ou aussi la
libération parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que lorsque j'étais à beyrouth
j'avais couvert leur enlèvement 85 et
donc j'avais toujours suivi cette
affaire deux autres otages notamment
lorsque moi même j'avais été pris en
otage il savait que vous aviez été vous
même autorisé par la cgt assez étonné
parce que la première parole que m'a dit
je crois c'est jean paul kauffmann est
aussi marcel fontaine c'était on était
très inquiet pour toi c'est le lancement
c'est le monde à l'envers
on était très inquiet pour toi parce
qu'on nous avions entendu à la radio que
tu avais été enlevée et nous n'avons pas
nouvelle de toi et et j'étais vraiment
très touchés par ces sept premières
minutes durant lesquelles j'étais avec
eux et aussi bon donc leur joie le le
sourire de ces trois hommes aussi la
joie de jean charles marchiani et de
l'autre négociateurs et skandar sa femme
qui était très heureux d'avoir réussi
leur mission et je pense que c'était
c'est vraiment une victoire pour tout le
monde et sans doute des images vous
aussi des images force des images
pleines d'émotions qui se bousculent
dans la tête ça vous rappeler la
protesta blement d'autres événements
vous aviez connu oui surtout justement
surtout lorsque je voyais le sourire
très très très franc de mme arkani et de
l'homme d'affaires libanais lorsqu ils
nous regardaient les trois otages et moi
en train de parler en train de faire
l'interview il était tellement satisfait
que je revivais moi aussi je revivais
les laisser ces moments que j'avais vécu
entre beyrouth et et le retour à paris
dans le dans l'avion privé
jake hoffman quelle image conserverait
vous de cette journée c'est peut-être un
peu prématuré car vous aussi il ya des
tas de l'image qui se bousculent dans la
tête mais s'il fallait retenir une image
forcément l'image sa descente de l'avion
n'avait pas contrairement aux autres
otages en avait pas on n'a pas l'image
de puisqu'il faut arriver un pont sur
pib comme ça ils n'ont pas été filmée là
bas nous on était là on attendait de
voir sa tête jean paul cécité si c'est
l'image la plus forte en tout cas si
vous avez pu parler je suppose avec
georges avec jean-paul quelle que soit
la petite cohue qui avait sur l'aéroport
vous at il parlé de ses ravisseurs
oui c'est pas le syndrome de stockholm
non pas du tout il appuie l'idée serait
en parle il n'y a pas de pardon de sa
part absolument aucune année là je sais
pas si certains à ce qu'on mérite pas du
tout aucune aucune aucune excuse
s'est il amusé parole très forte à ce
sujet mais je pense qu'il paraît il
parlera mieux tout ça j'espère que nous
l'aurons très bientôt sur le plateau
nous nous retrouvons vous restez avec
nous madame kaufmann et en géo que tout
au long de cette édition spéciale dans
quelques instants donc nous écouterons
les réactions aussi bien en france qu'à
l'étranger
mais avant cela pour mieux saisir
l'émotion qui était celle des familles
et reçoit des amis des familles voici
d'autres instantanée d'autres
témoignages recueillis par les équipes
d'antenne de commentaire raymond portera
20h30 environ le directeur de campagne
de jacques chirac tente un petit papier
à philippe seguin
ce dernier n'en croit pas ses yeux le
portage de chirac hésite se ravise
revient vérifier c'est bien cela les
otages français ont été libérés il va
donner le bia jacques sirat
hier soir encore à des milliers de
kilomètres dans l'île de la réunion à
sainte clotilde le père de marcel
fontaine 71 ans ne trouve pas les mots
pour exprimer sa joie bon moment j'ai
mis du temps à réagir et à partir du
moment où le deuxième des pêches est
arrivé là c'était l'explosion
je vous assure que j'ai senti que le
monde s'effondrer autour de moi que je
l'avais moi même plus aucune consistance
était soulagé fou de joie et je ne
savais tout pas parce qu elle sportive
en bretagne à cornus le village des
parents de jean paul avec les amis qui
ont envahi la maison
odette et marcel kaufmann trinquent tout
simplement au retour de leur fils enfin
cet après midi à beyrouth denis ce
carton et sa petite fille prennent
l'avion pour regagner paris où les
attendent depuis ce matin le grand-père
le plus heureux du monde
voilà votre reprenant très concrètement
le film des événements de la libération
des otages est donc intervenu hier soir
vers 19h30
officiellement la nouvelle a été
confirmée à à 20h25 nous l'avions
d'ailleurs donné en direct sur antenne 2
dès hier soir le chef de l'état françois
mitterrand avait exprimé son émotion et
sa satisfaction en direct de l'elysée
écoutez mesdames et messieurs la
libération de messieurs marcel carton
marcel fontaine et jean paul kauffmann
me remplit de joie ou non du pays tout
entier
j'exprime à nos trois compatriotes ainsi
qu'à leurs familles
d'une part notre soulagement les voir
revenir parmi nous à leurs familles la
compassion que nous inspire une si
longue épreuve je suis heureux que les
efforts entrepris depuis le début de ce
drame est enfin abouti et je remercie
tous ceux qui ont oeuvré pour ce retour
nous aurons aussi une pensée pour celui
qui n'est pas revenu michel seurat et
pour les siens ainsi que pour les otages
étrangers encore retenus ou libre voilà
j'ajoute que françois mitterrand a
constamment suivi l'évolution de la
situation il a même laissé entendre
devant quelques confrères que depuis
quelques jours certains indices
permettait d'entrevoir un dénouement
favorable
le chef de l'état s'est rendu cet après
midi au val de grâce pour saluer les
trois ex otages français je vous
rappelle que marcel carton marcel
fontaine et jean paul kauffmann
resteront en observation val de grâce
et ce pendant 48 heures ce matin sur
l'aéroport de villacoublay le premier
ministre jacques chirac a remercié tour
à tour l'iran le chef de l'état syrien
jacques chirac a ensuite précisé que le
rétablissement de relations normales
entre la france et l'iran pouvaient être
envisagées je vous propose de l'écouter
tout de suite toute la france se
partagent un même sentiment se voir et
aussi d'émotion c'est le carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann
fronde de france est libéré après avoir
enduré pendant si longtemps cru n'est
pas fini et je rends hommage à leurs
cours avec leur retour sachets le beauf
marc vécue par nos compatriotes détenus
au liban mais aussi les angoisses de
leurs familles mais au moment où nous
accueillons nos derniers otages comment
ne pas avoir une pensée émue et
particulière vos michel seurat qui ne
revient pas comme on le prévient vide et
aussi à l'esprit ce qu'endurent encore
les otages étrangers votre joli
je remercie le gouvernement iranien pour
son aide et pour ses diverses
interventions qui ont permis la
libération de nos compatriotes
j'exprime également ma gratitude au
président hafez al assad pour son action
personnelle et l'intérêt particulier
qu'il a porté à la solution de cette
douloureuse affaire dans un souci de
respect des principes et des valeurs
humaines
j'adresse aussi des remerciements aux
autorités militaires libanais pour leur
contribution ajoute que cet heureux
dénouement a été rendue possible par
l'activité déployée par un ami de la
france et de l'iran acquis j'exprime ma
reconnaissance et je tiens enfin
adresser mes félicitations à monsieur
jean charles marchiani et à son équipe
avec laquelle par l'intermédiaire de
monsieur pasqua
j'ai été constamment en liaison
comme chacun le sait la libération de
nos otages s'inscrit dans le contexte de
nos relations avec l'iran ce sont les
autorités de téhéran qui sont intervenus
auprès des ravisseurs pour qu'ils
relâchent nos compatriotes
ces nouvelles libérations nous les
attendions depuis des semaines des mois
elles sont en effet le résultat bien
trop longtemps retardée du même effort
qui avait déjà permis le retour de roger
auque et de jean louis normandin en
novembre dernier
dès lors que la détention de nos hôtes
un joli vent a pris fin le
rétablissement de relations normales
entre la france et l'iran peut être
envisagée conformément à notre
conception de ce que doivent être les
rapports entre états
j'ajoute que nous voulons interpréter le
retour de nos compatriotes comme un
signe en direction de la france mais
aussi des autres pays occidentaux
j'espère de tout coeur que dans cette
perspective les otages étrangers seront
bientôt eux aussi rendu à la liberté
inévitablement des interrogations des
doutes vont se faire jour sur le
processus qui a permis le retour de nos
compatriotes comme ce fut le cas lors
des libérations précédent je ne veux pas
chercher à connaître les motivations de
ceux qui chez nous ou ailleurs en y
avait tard propage pas propagé telle ou
telle abnégation
j'affirme simplement que tout au long de
cette si douloureuse affaire
le gouvernement avec persévérance n'a
cessé d'agir dans la dignité et dans
l'honneur
personne ne peut le contester
nous sommes conformer strictement aux
valeurs que nous avons en commun avec
les autres pays démocratiques
nous avons respecté scrupuleusement les
grands principes de notre politique
étrangère
nous sommes restés parfaitement fidèle à
nos amitiés et à nos engagements au
moyen-orient aujourd'hui plus que jamais
la france est déterminée à poursuivre
avec la plus grande fermeté le combat
contre le terrorisme avec tous ceux qui
comme elle croit au droit à la justice
et au respect de la personne
oui nouvelle interview nouvelles
déclarations il ya quelques instants sur
les ondes de nos confrères d'europe 1
françois mitterrand a refusé l'idée de
toute complicité dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme je vous propose d'écouter
tout de suite
la déclaration du chef de l'état je
n'accepte pas et vous ne m'en a pas
parlé
les insinuations et les diffamations
dont j'ai été l'objet à ce moment là
lorsqu'il était prétendu que aussi bien
par rapport à la nouvelle chronique par
rapport aux affaires de terroristes un
peu partout il pouvait y avoir pour
attirer par votre complicité objective
les moindres clin d'oeil du président de
la république française à l'égard de ces
gens que j'ai toujours combattu auquel
je refusais tout grâce et encore cette
fois ci j'ai prélevé la fusion me l'a
pas proposé
mais quelle dans les circonstances
présentes je n'aurait évidemment pas
accepter et voilà que soudain vous
voulez que je sois démunis de tout
élément de réponse alors que moi
j'assiste où j'ai assisté à des
attitudes de souplesse du son pour le
mot et je suis discret mois la gare de
souplesse à l'égard d'un certain nombre
de terroristes qui ont quand même
retrouvé la liberté dans des conditions
qui peuvent être expliqués mais qui ne
permettent pas de prétendre qu'on est
intransigeant avec que terol
voilà revenons à la libération des trois
derniers otages français au liban
l'histoire retiendra que cette
libération est intervenue le 4 mai 88 à
quelques jours seulement de l'élection
présidentielle l'histoire qui est
jalonnée de dates retiendra également
qu'il aura fallu plus de trois ans et
oui plus de trois ans pour libérer les
otages français
martine laroche joubert
22 mars 1985 marcel carton et marcel
fontaine sont enlevés à beyrouth-ouest
par le jihad islamique organisation
intégriste pro iranienne qui exigent
l'arrêt du soutien français à l'irak
le lendemain 22 mars c'est au tour de
gilles pérol directeur du centre
culturel de tripoli retenu par les farl
des chrétiens marxiste qui le relâche le
2 avril en échange semble-t-il de la
libération d'abdallah toujours
emprisonnés en france 22 mai sur la
route de l'aéroport enlèvement de jean
paul kauffmann et du chercheur michel
seurat les ravisseurs le djihad
islamique encore leurs exigences la
libération du commando chapour bakhtiar
près d'un an après le 5 mars 86 le
djihad islamique annonce l'exécution de
michel seurat d'après jean paul
kauffmann il serait mort d'un cancer
trois jours après la mort annoncée de
michel sera le 8 mars 86 l'équipe
d'antenne 2 est enlevée par le jr
l'organisation de la justice
révolutionnaire de mouvance iranienne
qui dénonce l'ensemble de la politique
française au proche orient le 20 juin
philippe rochot et georges hansen sont
libérés le 24 décembre c'est au tour
d'oreille cornea tandis que jean louis
normandin restent emprisonnés la même
année 86
deux autres français sont libérés
camille sont à 2 84 ans et marcel
khoudary mais le 13 janvier 87
l'histoire recommence projet aux
journalistes est enlevée il sera libéré
le 27 novembre 87 par le jr en même
temps que jean louis normandin d'antenne
2 il n'y a plus aujourd'hui d'otages
français aux mains d'extrémistes
libanais
oui martine parlais à l'instant de
logivière du jihad islamique je crois
qu'il n'est peut-être pas inutile pierre
serra de rappeler qu'ils sont ces
groupuscules très très actif ce sont des
beautés des groupuscules
en fait il ya beaucoup en général ils
sont composés de chiites extrémistes
libanais qui appartiennent à une
mouvance pro iranienne notamment au
parti de dieu le hezbollah il faut
comprendre qu'il ya beaucoup de groupes
il ya donc louvière qui le principal
lauréat sur le site révolutionnaire qui
va enlever philippe rochot notamment et
puis il ya le djihad islamique et je
vous rappelle que le djihad en arabe ça
veut dire guerre sainte c'est donc
religieux et puis à beaucoup d'autres il
ya l'organisation des révolutionnaires
musulmans socialiste lors isation des
déshérités sur terre enfin j'en passe
beaucoup
tout ça pour faire comprendre que ces
groupuscules sont possèdent parfois une
sorte de génération spontanée
en fait ils sont créés pour les besoins
de la cause ils disparaissent aussi vite
et en fait leur intitulé sert de
couverture au mouvement qui les et qui
génère en vous pur ans le plus souvent
en tout cas il s'agit de l'asbl certaine
libération d'otages aurait sans doute pu
se dérouler et intervenir beaucoup plus
tôt mais il faut savoir que des
contentieux politiques militaires
également des contentieux financiers ont
souvent bloqué l'issue des négociations
à ces blocages se sont également ajoutés
des actes de terrorisme qui ont fait
malheureusement monter la pression
explications de jean marc il use au
coeur du contentieux franco-iranien il
ya d'abord une guerre celle que se
livrent depuis huit ans l'irak et l'iran
plusieurs centaines de milliers de morts
et de blessés or la france après l'urss
et le deuxième fournisseur d'armes de
l'irak
facturé en milliards de francs mirage
missiles hélicoptères et surtout des
systèmes de guidage électronique
terriblement efficace
après avoir d'abord exigé sans succès la
suspension pure et simple de l'aide
française à l'irak l'iran et les groupes
terroristes qui le soutiennent
réclameront une politique plus
équilibrée
en clair de pouvoir acheter les mêmes
armes que leur ennemi iranien
la france a toujours dit non mais à
paris comme ailleurs
aucun gouvernement n'est chapeau aux
accusations de vente clandestine d'armes
à l'iran deuxième source de conflit la
présence en france d'opposants iraniens
condamnés par le régime de téhéran
asile politique pour l'ancien chef de
gouvernement banny ça dans 81 et surtout
pour massoud radjavi chef des
moudjahidines du peuple
son expulsion enjoint 86 permettra la
libération de philippe rochot georges en
scène l'expulsion de ses partisans en
décembre 87 sera un nouveau signe de la
poursuite des interminables tractations
entre paris et téhéran
troisième source de conflits les actes
terroristes monte à téhéran cinq
terroristes emprisonnés en france après
un attentat sanglant en juillet 80 ne
seront jamais libéré mais en novembre 87
wahid gordji numéro deux de l'ambassade
d'iran suspects de complicité dans les
attentats qui firent 11 morts et 150
blessés en plein paris en septembre 86
sera soudain lavé de tout soupçon son
départ de paris mettra fin à quatre mois
de guerre des ambassades et surtout
surviendra deux jours à peine après la
libération de roger auque et jean louis
normandin le 25 mars
88 nouveau coup de théâtre mohamed
mourad gère un français d'origine
libanaise également soupçonné dans les
mêmes attentats de septembre 86 sera à
son tour libéré après un an de détention
libération interprété comme un signal de
paris aux iraniens et à leurs partisans
libanais quatrième contentieux le
contentieux financier
d'un côté la dette d'un milliard de
dollars contracté par la france aux
temps du shah d'iran
de l'autre les intérêts des firmes
françaises les et pendant la révolution
islamique
deux tiers de ces dettes remboursées par
la france en 86 peut-être un troisième
demain si un accord existe enfin sur le
montant des intérêts payables par paris
pour marcel fontaine marcel carton et
jean paul kauffmann et pour tous ceux
qui ne
aussi leur libération la dernière ligne
droite a été jalonné d'échecs et aussi
de rebondissements retentissant souvenez
vous par exemple du détournement d'avion
déco et r'ways le détournement est
intervenue au moment précis où l'on tel
est pratiquement pour acquise la
libération des otages hervé brusini la
crau l'imprévu le voilà ce boeing déco
et airlines immobilisé sur l'aéroport
d'alger
c'était à la mi avril une trentaine de
passagers et un commando qui réclame la
libération de dix sept extrémistes
chiites détenus au koweit
la mécanique de la négociation sur les
otages français est bloqué ceux qui
tiennent cet avion appartiennent à la
même mouvance que les ravisseurs de
cartons fontaine et kaufman 20 avril la
médiation algérienne dénoue la crise et
deux jours plus tard un falcon 50 se
pose sur l'aéroport de larnaca à son
bord les émissaires français parmi eux
jean charles marchiani
voici la seule image de cet homme de
l'ombre ce businessman ancien lieutenant
du contre espionnage français au passé
tumultueux il était en liaison
permanente avec charles pasqua lors
conversation téléphonique se faisait en
langue corse
mais ce jour là le voyage de retour a eu
lieu sans les otages
un revirement cauet tient dans des
promesses faites sur l'allègement des
peines délices est détenu en est peut
être la raison
autre en mots clés du dossier otages
iskandar safa chrétiens libanais homme
d'affaires ami du président syrien
il serait l'un des banquiers de l'iran à
beyrouth peut-être est-ce là me saluer
par jacques chirac dans sa déclaration
et qui suis un homme d'action à la vous
le connaissez vous pourriez nous en
parler un tout petit peu non il était
bien dans cet effet simplement sans quoi
que jamais a cédé 7 un ami de la france
comme beaucoup de chrétiens libanais
alors disons que fanny heures que leur
seconde patrie à la france et ils font
parfois pour la france des choses que
d'autres ne font pas eh bien écoutez je
pense que vous avez presque tout dit
jeudi à s'entraîner je n'ai pas dit
qu'il s'agissait de lui
vous êtes à mes affaires j'ai simplement
dit qu'elles étaient ces qualités nous
je ne sais pas si cet ami de l'iran
l'algérie on sait a également facilité
pour des raisons humanitaires le
règlement des dernières opérations de
cette libération
mais ce qui a provoqué l'accélération du
dénouement reste encore pour l'instant
une ennemie
alors qu'hier serra essayons d'y voir
plus clair essayons surtout de
décortiquer le mécanisme des
négociations a priori les négociations
se déroulent d'état et à cette nouvelle
demande et bien sûr il ya plusieurs
états évidemment il d'abord le liban il
faut bien qu il faut bien considérer
liban lui c'est un état mais les réduit
est dans un tel état justement que son
rôle est uniquement tas de permettre en
quelque sorte bien les hommes en otage
donc il peut pas il est là en comme
terrain de toutes cultures si vous
voulez et puis à la syrie c'est un état
puissant dans la région c'est un état
qui a occupé qui gère entre guillemets
une grande partie du liban
et cet état là il allait beaucoup de
moyens dans la région mais il peut
empêcher une solution qui nous convient
pas mais pas forcément imposée celle qui
lui convient et puis reste l'iran l'iran
qui a réussi au liban a importé en tout
cas sa révolution islamique et on le
voit qu'ils exercent une influence
déterminante sur les groupes du
hezbollah alors quelles filières avons
utilisé par milieu de tout ça on a
utilisé la syrie d'abord parce que la
syrie qui est présente au liban à les
contacter connaît les arcanes les
filières pour arriver à toucher les gens
qui eux appartiennent au hezbollah sont
pro iranien et ainsi de suite pour y
reprendre contact avec les ravisseurs
c'est ce qu'a fait pierre on en est sûr
il n'y a pas eu de contact direct et
physique avec les ravisseurs
ah je pense qu'il y en a eu parce que
c'était inévitable il faut à partir du
moment ou un autre
arrivé à ce que monsieur marqué d'une
autre on parle aux ravisseurs et leur
disent 'voilà prenez-moi au sérieux moi
j'ai des engagements je peux les tenir
voilà ce qu'on peut faire le
gouvernement qui a directement négocié
avec les requins vous avez les hommes de
l'ombre sont faits pour ça le
gouvernement traite avec des états et
des ambassadeurs il a des ministres il
se traite avec des états puis les hommes
de l'ombre font leur métier
c'est comme ça rangez vos vous voulez
ajouter quelque chose je voulais
préciser qu effectivement il ya des
contacts directs entre les négociateurs
vont se remarque annie iskandar safa et
les ravisseurs sur le terrain notamment
des contacts téléphoniques
je pense que c'est pas un secret être
maintenant marchiani vous avez expliqué
danger bubry explique effectivement lors
de la libération avait expliqué que pour
lui il était important d'avoir un
contact humain et c'est pour ça qu'il
m'avait dit que en tant que corps s'il
aimait ce contact qu'on trouve un peu en
orient et qu' il misait beaucoup sur
cela et en orient c'est très important
d'avoir un contact de naw voyons tout de
suite les principales réactions
politiques qui nous sont parvenus
aujourd'hui le sentiment général c'est
d'abord de la reconnaissance pour ceux
qui ont permis la libération des otages
de part et d'autre on exclut toute
récupération
politique de l'événement écoutons j'ai
entendu le débat télévisé où le
président de la république a dit à
quelles conditions les otages pouvaient
être libérés
monsieur le premier ministre a dit qu'il
en était d'accord je n'ai donc aucune
raison de penser que des concessions
étaient faites lorsque monsieur pasqua
s'exprime je l'entends je me dis s'il
dit vrai alors tout est bien pour la
france sur le plan personnel comme
citoyen comme individu je me réjouis de
la fin de l'épreuve de ces malheureux et
de l' angoisse de leur famille
mais sur le plan politique comme homme
politique
je trouve que la méthode discussions
avec les organisations terroristes est
condamnable
il ya trois ans qu'ils étaient détenus
depuis trois ans jour pour jour nous
luttons pour que s'ouvrent des
négociations
enfin ces négociations abouties nous
sommes heureux de saluer leur courage et
de leur souhaiter bon retour dans leur
famille et dans la communauté nationale
oui tout de suite le constat paul amar
si j'ai bien compris tout le monde
exclut la récupération politique de
l'événement
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais ce qui
surprend tout de même aujourd'hui dans
une certaine mesure c'est le contraste
entre le bonheur des otages libérés le
bonheur de leurs familles et la
crispation des hommes politiques bien
sûr cette crispation est masquée par les
discours où l'on entend depuis hier soir
les mots qu'il faut entendre
joie soulagement remerciements bien sûr
cette crispation est masqué par le
consensus apparent et par le constat
unanime le gouvernement s'est montré
efficace
il a réussi à obtenir la libération de
tous les otages c'est bien tout le monde
l'admet mais il ya une question que ce
même monde politique se pose à voix
basse
évidemment pourquoi cette libération at
elle eu lieu hier à trois jours du
deuxième tour
quelle incidence aura t-elle sur le vote
des français personnes dans la classe
politique n'ose la poser publiquement
parce que personne n'ose aujourd'hui
exploité cette libération dans un sens
ou dans un autre
heureusement ce serait en effet une
erreur erreur psychologique à l'égard de
kaufman de cartons et de fontaines qui
sont aujourd'hui libres
qui ne doivent pas devenir à nouveau des
otages les otages d'une élection
présidentielle
erreur à la gare des électeurs qui vont
voter dimanche dans le secret de
l'isoloir le feront ils en fonction de
ce nouvel événement
impossible de répondre de répondre en
tout cas à leur place erreur enfin à
l'égard des ravisseurs homme ou est un
qui nous ont manipulés pendant trois ans
nous médias et hommes politiques comme
ils continuent de nous manipuler
aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui décident en
effet de notre angoisse comme de notre
joie il aurait pu libérer les otages il
ya trois mois il ya six mois il aurait
pu le faire après le 8 mai ils ont
préféré les libérer à trois jours du
scrutin
comme s'il prenait un malin plaisir à
intervenir dans notre campagne
électorale comme s'ils pouvaient eux des
terroristes décider du sort de
l'élection
en tous les cas c'est la fin du
cauchemar pour les trois derniers otages
français mais jean paul kauffmann le
disait fort justement tout à l'heure 14
otages occidentaux sont toujours retenus
au liban parmi eux dix américains un
italien un irlandais un allemand et un
britannique
à cette longue liste il convient
d'ajouter malheureusement la famille
valente
celle qui était vous le savez à bord du
cilq haut le bateau qui a été arraisonné
au large de gaza en méditerranée
les huit passagers du bateau sont
toujours aux mains du groupe palestinien
fatah conseil révolutionnaire cheikh
abou nidal
aujourd'hui la famille valente dénonce
l'oubli de cette prise d'otages
pascal deschamps six mois presque jour
pour jour que marie laure et virginie
filmé ici par leurs ravisseurs sont
détenus par le groupe abou nidal pour
leur père ce sont les otages oublier
qu'être satisfait très content d'avoir
ces trois hommes a libéré une qui vous
fait passer énormément de souffrance
un amour non de souffrance mais j'étais
déçu après par l'érection de
beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui n'ont
pas eu une petite pensée pendant et leur
virginie vous ne parlez que d'otages
étrangers tous les otages français sont
libérés jacqueline valente ses deux
fillettes et ses cinq amis belges
avaient quitté la france il ya deux ans
ah ben du cil co et puis plus de
nouvelles
jusqu'au coup de théâtre du 8 novembre
87 le groupe abu nidal annonce alors
l'arraisonnement du bateau et la capture
de ses occupants accusés d'être des
espions à la solde d'israël
après trois mois de silence les
ravisseurs diffusent des messages de
jacqueline valente qui accouche d'une
petite fille pendant sa détention et de
fernand hopkins qui affirme ce sont les
services secrets israéliens qui m'ont
demandé de venir en israël avec ma
famille personne n'a pu les rencontrer
ni la croix rouge ni lucien beat herlin
président de l'association france pays
arabes qui pensaient pouvoir obtenir la
libération des deux fillettes à beyrouth
fin janvier pour les autorités
françaises les accusations des
ravisseurs sont sans fondement
l'enlèvement de ces huit personnes
restent un mystère la libération des
otages français suscite bon nombre de
réactions à l'étranger les réactions les
plus durs sont enregistrés à londres de
l'autre côté du channel dès hier soir
londres réclamé des explications le chef
du parti social démocrate a même
qualifié le site de cynique
l'accord conclu par les français
philippe harrouard à londres la
libération des otages français dont on
se réjouit ici ne fera pas changer d'un
iota la position officielle britannique
pas de négociations pas de marchandage
avec les ravisseurs ou ceux qui les
soutiennent
le journaliste john mccarthy restent
détenus au liban depuis deux ans déjà
ainsi que le collaborateur de
l'archevêque de canterbury perry white
le cousin de terry wey a redit
aujourd'hui que lui même et sa famille
étaient en accord avec la ligne
inflexible de madame thatcher
tout comme la quasi-totalité de
l'opinion publique ton différent chez
jean morel la fiancée de john mccarthy
qui critiquent l'immobilisme de l'autre
français a raison
de sade aux assauts pressurage et
coordonner les otages et j'espère que le
gouvernement s'engage dans les journaux
on se fait volontiers l'écho de rumeurs
sur une éventuelle rançon versée par la
france aux ravisseurs selon les
commentaires il y a eu au moins un
piment d'argent et sinon la promesse de
libération d'un terroriste
mais ça on ne sait pas encore et c'est
ça que madame thatcher a dit qu'elle
voulait et vous êtes voulait être
renseignés comme lors de la libération
d'autres otages français on pourrait
bien assister ici à une poussée de
fièvre anti française aux etats unis
pendant ce temps dans la libération des
otages a été accueillie avec
circonspection c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire la maison blanche se réjouit
pour les otages français mais attend des
informations supplémentaires sur place
nos correspondants permanents
jacques bouchard paul nahon nous nous
réjouissons du retour des otages
français en souhaitant que d'autres
libérations interviennent au liban a
déclaré marlene fils water porte parole
de la maison blanche sans autre
commentaire
il a évité de s'étendre car le scandale
de l'irangate encore présent dans toutes
les mémoires avait éclaboussé
l'entourage de ronald reagan et provoqué
un séisme politique en amérique
ici au département d'état on était resté
étranger aux tractations sur les ventes
d'armes à l'iran en échange de la
libération d'otages américains on
s'exprime donc sans complexe sur le
retour de messieurs carton fontaine et
jean paul kauffmann nous serions très
préoccupés a dit un porte parole
par l'idée que des concessions ont pu
être faites aux ravisseurs les
concessions ne font qu'encourager
d'autres enlèvements et ne peuvent que
prolonger la captivité des otages
toujours détenus les américains n'oublie
pas que neuf de leurs compatriotes
enlevés au liban sont toujours aux mains
de leurs ravisseurs
le dernier en date est le
lieutenant-colonel higgins kidnappés au
sud du liban où ils servaient dans les
rangs de la finul sous le drapeau des
nations unies
voilà avant de refaire de refermer ce
dossier nous allons nous tourner une
nouvelle fois vers marcel fontaine
marcel carton et jean paul kauffmann qui
sont vous le savez en observation à
l'hôpital du val-de-grâce observations
de 48 heures après près de 2000 jours
plus de mille jours d'ailleurs de
détention que peut-il se passer pour eux
dr ph suppose qu'ils vont devoir prendre
un peu de recul 1 et surtout comprendre
que le monde a bougé pendant leur
détention
oui le danger qui peut se passer c'est
l'inadéquation entre moments qui sont
rentrés en détention et le moment où ils
vont revenir dans le monde dans le monde
qui vivent et ce qui peut qu'on peut
craindre un certain moment c'est que
pour survivre comme cela a été dit et ce
matin il se soit un peu refermés sur
eux-mêmes de façon tout à fait naturelle
pour sorte résister à cette absence
d'environnement et leur passage à la vie
de tous les jours à la vie quotidienne
peut être un passage difficile c'est là
où il est important d'avoir des
interlocuteurs privilégiés des amis une
famille parfois une écoute un peu neutre
celle d'un psychiatre ou un psychologue
ou une autre technique et celle aussi
d'écrire un livre qui une façon quelque
sorte d'exorciser le mal c'est ce qui
est fait et roger auque il en parlera
tout à l'heure madame copains que vous
avez l'impression que jean paul était en
bonne santé jaillir en bonne santé c'est
peut-être pas le faire mais qu'il se
sentait bien ce matin il avait l'air
relativement serein solidaire on les
disait vrai quelqu'un qui était solide
déjà avant je crois que fait beaucoup
certainement mais bon il était solide
bien sûr aujourd'hui mais on sait tous
que bien sûr c'est pas si simple que ça
il ya trois ans de demandes
d'informations total de creux par
rapport à nous il ya quantité
d'événements qui n'a pas vécu puis l'a
vécu trés d'isoler nous on n'avait
qu'une ou dans la famille et tous les
amis une période extrêmement forte au
contraire avec beaucoup beaucoup de
l'événement dont il n'était pas lui tenu
au courant vous savez madame s'il
souhaitait prendre un peu de recul non
ce matin il a peut-être pas eu le temps
d'ailleurs d'en parler mais il a sauté
il avait très peur de la foule il avait
très peur du bruit il était très
culpabiliser parce que j'en peu les
mêmes qui donnent beaucoup la
culpabilité
il était très cool a visé en disant il
explique au journaliste que je peux
passer trop de monde à foix il faut me
donner quelques jours j'étais mère
maintenant et je sens qu'il est
complètement envie de rentrer dans
de recommencer tout il était déjà la
région nous tout ça merci de votre
témoignage on va essayer d'aller un
petit peu plus loin on va voir comment
ça s'est passé pour pour d'autres ex
otages roger auque est avec nous qui a
exorcisé un petit peu le mal en écrivant
un bouquin oui effectivement je pense
que il faut tout faire pour essayer de
placer cette période dramatique de la
considérons qu'elle soit comme une
mésaventure et l'a placé à l'intérieur
de quelque chose qui est plus positif
alors moi je m'efforce de placer ses 11
mois de détention
à l'intérieur de sacs années passées au
liban cinq années disons quatre années
du reportage positive et je garde un
excellent souvenir du vivant et je crois
aussi qu'il faut essayer de se
débarrasser de cette histoire c'est un
peu comme le patient qui s'allonge sur
le divan et qui livre son histoire son
angoisse au psychanalyste et je crois
que la meilleure manière son corps
d'écrire un livre et c'est ce que j'ai
fait je profite pour le montrer c'est ce
que j'ai fait en écrivant ce livre avec
art il faut rester chez filipacchi c'est
une manière de tourner la page de de se
débarrasser de cette angoisse et te dire
maintenant c'est fini on prend un
nouveau départ dans la vie
ça reste un mauvais reportage avant
portage que mal tourné on va essayer
d'avoir d'autres témoignages et de voir
comment ça s'est passé par exemple pour
philippe rochot pour aurel cornéa et
georges en scène qui tombe également
avec nous sur le plateau philippe rochot
jean louis normandin lé 18 ans après si
on ne s'était pas pareil parce que quand
on a été libéré avec georges on laissait
d'abord du camarade derrière donc on
avait envie nous de se défouler aussi de
parler parce que d'abord c'est une
aventure extraordinaire mais on pouvait
pas le faire parce qu'on savait que
toute information et toute provocation
pouvait être nuisible à nos camarades
donc nous on n'a pas encore écrit un
livre ça viendra peut-être un jour mais
nous avons eu aussi ce besoin de parler
et de s'exprimer et donc là moi j'avais
été surpris par exemple parce que j'ai
couvert la sphère du détournement du big
data wba en 1985 et j'avais vu que les
les otages américains étaient été pris
en charge et que précisément ils
pouvaient raconter leur aventure devant
un psychologue et là ce n'était pas
possible apparemment pour les autres
vous comment ça s'est passé
alors je crois que ça a été fait je
crois que ça a été fait pour nous pour
nous pour nos camarades et que
maintenant le problème est connu et que
tout et tout est organisé pour que tout
se passe bien pour eux et qu'ils
reprennent pied rapidement dans la vie
normale
jean louis normandin oui alors comment
ça s'est passé pour vous la journée où
nous voilà dans la journée je pense que
c'était un peu l'euphorie la joie de
retrouver les ex otages
c'était intéressant parce que la
première fois que je vais y arriver des
otages et
il y avait un raccourci entre le masque
d'émotion des enfants et le visage des
otages
les doubles et enfin serein très calme
c'est un beau raccourci pour moi et
d'une manière générale depuis la fin de
l'année 1987 depuis votre libération
comment ça s'est passé dans la tête
physiquement ça s'est relativement bien
passée bâton dit oui enfin j'espère
disons que c'est pas si simple et on a
besoin de reprendre je pense
relativement rapidement le travail sera
inséré dans le cadre normal de travail
et vous vous être parti en reportage
d'ailleurs on a vu on a entendu plus tôt
et vos premiers reportages c'est vrai
georges en selle le musée des libelles
avec philippe blot je partage le
problème était le même pour moi et c'est
vrai que ce qui a été le plus difficile
en fait à vivre c'est le retour jusqu'au
retour de jean louis normandin et dereck
fournier et là c'est vrai que j'ai
souffert d'un sentiment de culpabilité
g20 peu honte de ma liberté je te
difficile pour moi et mes docteurs
le plus dur pour un otage c'est
peut-être vous m'arrêtez c'est une
bêtise mais d'être sans cesse soumis à
l'alternance de l'espoir et et du pire
ça je pense qu'on doit le connaître au
quotidien c'est le sait le fait de ne
pas savoir et d'être en permanence
l'objet de manipulations et je pense que
c'est effectivement comme vous dites
cette espèce de tunnel où il n'y a pas
de fin qu'on puisse vais recevoir c'est
en quelque sorte cette espèce d'attentes
pendant laquelle il a été dit le c'était
une survie ça pète on dit c'était une
survie dans lequel des traumatismes
sûrement très important psychologiques
sont survenus qui en quelque sorte
potentialiser cette attente qui est ce
qu'on finissait par le retour est ce que
vous prenez l'affirmation au sérieux
quand on vous dit que les otages sont
guettés par le syndrome de stockholm on
en parlait tout à l'heure à savoir une
adhésion aux revendications des
ravisseurs
alors ça se passe dans des conditions
très particulier une sorte de stockholm
survient généralement lorsque les
ravisseurs ne sont pas masqué lorsqu'il
a des contacts très proche
là il était je crois les visiteurs et
des ravisseurs étaient ne voyez pas le
visage et
et finalement le centre de stockholm
survient lorsque on va croire à ce qui
est dit par les ravisseurs ce qui n'est
pas là le cas je crois de plus merci
docteur merci de votre témoignage merci
madame d'être avec nous et depuis hier
soir
merci à vous tous merci nous avons été
très très gens sensibles à votre geste
et et nous avons tout fait sur antenne 2
vous le savez oui je sais c'est possible
de la décision des familles comme tous
les gens qui nous ont dit ce qu'ils ont
travaillé ici j'espère que dans les
jours qui viennent nous nous
retrouverons en votre compagnie en
compagnie jean paul kauffmann et de
marcel carné sur ce plateau
merci à tous voyons maintenant le le
reste de l'actualité en commençant par
la libération des otages d'ouvéa en
nouvelle-calédonie
l'assaut donné par la gendarmerie a duré
vous le savez près de huit heures les
otages sont sains et saufs mais
l'opération a fait 17 victimes
reportage françois cornet essayé dans
cette affaire de d'apporter des éléments
sur sur deux tableaux j'ai vraiment tout
fait pour que cette situation cesse
pacifiquement je n'y suis pas parvenu
malheureusement et j'ai donc fait mon
devoir de militaires s'étaient j'ai tout
mis en oeuvre pour le succès de pour
aider au succès de cette opération
militaire
l'honneur du gign et de la gendarmerie
s'offre aujourd'hui il est parfaitement
ce qu'il d'autant plus sauf que le
capitaine picon qui est ici et amener de
l'intérieur une opération comment ça
s'est passé
bah ce qui nous a permis de tenir le
coup aussi longtemps c'était le fait de
savoir déjà que l'extérieur déjà
s'occuper de nous et le fait d'avoir de
pouvoir être utile depuis l'intérieur ce
que nous avons essayé de faire en
protégeant la vie des camarades qui
étaient aussi otage avec au cours d'une
conférence de presse bernard pons le
ministre des dom-tom affirmé qu'il y
avait encore une dizaine de bandes armés
en nouvelle-calédonie je cite ces propos
ensuite bernard pons a exclu tout
dialogue avec les terroristes et demandé
une nouvelle fois la dissolution du fln
terrestre reportage dominique tierces
opération victor tel était le nom de
code de l'intervention menée ce matin à
partir de 5 heures sur l'île d'ouvéa
les hommes du général vidal n'avait
qu'une mission récupérer les gendarmes
et le substitut du procureur détenu pour
certains depuis 14 jours dans une grotte
au nord de la tribu de gossanah il y à
moins d'une heure bernard pons expliqué
que depuis le 3 mai jacques chirac lui
avait donné son accord pourtant faire un
assaut après consultation des autorités
militaires
l'intervention avait été fixé à
aujourd'hui techniquement l'opération a
été conduite par les hommes du gign
aidés par les unités commandos des
armées au tableau comme la semaine
dernière le ministre précise que
d'importants combats se sont engagés
autour de la grotte ils n'ont cessé que
vers midi dans les rangs des gendarmes
trois blessés dont un dans un état grave
chez les militaires de morts chez les
indépendantistes une quinzaine de
victimes et de nombreux blessés
lorsque l'action a été déclenchée où les
otages se sont réfugiés dans le fond de
la grotte bien en particulier ils se
sont mis ici à l'angle était le
capitaine picon ici c'est un tas de
terre un gros tas de terre et derrière
se tape terre étaient le maréchal des
logis chef du bois fin et saufs tous les
otages ont pu quitter la grotte vers 14h
soulagement et satisfaction ce soir à
nouméa
cette affaire était une affaire qui
concerne l etat c'était une affaire qui
implique et l'honneur de la france
c'était une affaire qui concerne l
honneur de l'armée française et
l'honneur de la gendarmerie
c'était donc une affaire qui devait être
dégagés de tout contexte politique
c'est ce que je me suis en permanence et
forcé de faire pendant tous ces jours où
j'ai eu sur instruction du premier
ministre et au nom du gouvernement a
dirigé les opérations
le ministre des dom tom a néanmoins
recommandé la dissolution du fln caisse
ce soir tous les partis politiques
locaux salue l'action des forces de
sécurité la sphère d'ouvéa est à présent
terminée tout au long de cette prise
d'otages le rôle du capitaine legorjus a
été déterminant depuis le 28 avril au
soir
le capitaine du gign faisait l'aller
retour entre la caserne meunier à nouméa
et la grotte où étaient retenus les 21
gendarmes et le substitut du procureur
c'est lui qui a réussi à faire parvenir
sur les lieux de la détention des vivres
des médicaments des couvertures très
régulièrement le capitaine legorjus
assistait aux réunions de sécurité tenue
par berbatov ici même au commissariat
ils transmettaient directement les
revendications des ravisseurs
c'est à dire l'élargissement du
périmètre de sécurité le ravitaillement
la reconstruction de la tribu de sanaa
les tweets partiellement dès les
premières opérations militaires dans la
nuit du 2 non le capitaine du gign la
plus transmettre personnellement à deux
de ses hommes de revolver ainsi plus le
clé pour enlever leurs méthodes dernière
réaction vous allez l'entendre celle du
bureau politique du fln ks le bureau
demande à ses militants de relever le
défi du colonialisme pour le fln ks la
lutte continue ce jour est un jour de un
pour le peuple français qui comptable
devant la communauté des nations
civilisées de cette barbarie coloniale
et de surbourg au kiss une trappe de
l'honneur de la france pour préserver au
prix de la haine et du mépris des
privilèges dans notre tante
le bureau politique du fln k s appelle
tous les militants dans tous les comités
de lutte de kanaky à relever ce nouveau
défi du colonialisme l'heure est à la
mobilisation
la lutte continue voilà sachez encore
qu'il y à quelques minutes toujours sur
l'antenne d'europe 1 françois mitterrand
a abordé la sphère de nouvelle calédonie
je vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
le chef de l'état j'ai préconisé la
conciliation
et lorsqu'il a été question faute de
conciliation de parvenir à une opération
de type militaire
mais j'ai demandé le gouvernement aussi
lier tout et quand toutes les garanties
possibles et imaginables
c'est à dire des rapports écrits des
chefs militaires responsables pour
qu'ils étudient absolument tous les
aspects d'une question aussi difficile
et tout le temps que ces rapports ont
laissé entendre que l'opération est très
coûteuse en vies humaines
elle a été refusée j'ai donc besoin
maintenant de vérifier
il y avait de vérifier un dossier les
conditions dans lesquelles l'action
s'est déroulée très loin d'ici
hors de ma vue et que l'on contrôle
direct je trouve très douloureux cette
situation le fait qu'il y ait une 15-15
sur 17 15 kanak ne change rien à faire
ce sont des citoyens français
j'ai un devoir de protection à l'égard
des uns et des autres mais mon premier
devoir était quand même à l'égard des
otages car c'est un acte est il
admissible que les réactions se
succèdent vous allez voir à lyon aux
côtés de raymond barre où il était cet
après midi jacques chirac est lui aussi
abordé la sphère de nouvelle calédonie
la sphère des otages d'ouvéa
reportage laurent bouvier comme le dit
lucien de viable qui connaît ses
classiques l'espoir changea de camp le
combat changea d'âme
depuis hier soir depuis ce matin tout a
changé effectivement dans le camp
chiraquien le déjeuner républicain à
midi à lyon en fournissait la preuve on
avait mis les états d'âme au rancart et
les petits plats majoritaire dans les
grands plats et même liste
je formule le voeu que dans le respect
des lois de la république française il
puisse y avoir en nouvelle calédonie un
retour à la paix un retour au dialogue
entre les communautés
un retour à une politique de
développement économique social et
humain qui est la meilleure garantie de
la présence de la france sur ce
territoire du pacifique et jacques
chirac le feindre de ne pas avoir
entendu une exhortation barriste faut
répondre du tac au tac
j'appelle tous les calédoniens
responsable à s'engager ensemble sur la
voie de la compréhension mutuelle du
dialogue et de la résolution pacifique
des problèmes qui se posent dans ce
territoire français et qui a une large
majorité toutes ethnies confondues à 10
sans ambiguïté lors du référendum
d'autodétermination
comme lors des élections du 24 avril sa
volonté de rester français et qui par
conséquent ne saurait être exclue ou
rejeter de la communauté nationale en
corse à ajaccio où il s'est rendu dans
l'après-midi le candidat chirac ne s'est
glorifié ni de la libération des otages
du liban ni de celle des gendarmes du
bea
tout juste s'est-il à marseille ce soir
permis de faire référence à la nouvelle
calédonie pour mieux stigmatiser les
indépendantistes éventé l'ordre
républicain
jacques chirac laisse à d'autres dans
son entourage le soin à bout dimanche de
faire monter la mayonnaise
le bilan de l'opération d'ouvéa qui a
fait je vous le rappelle dix sept morts
six blessés 15 arrestations suscite
quelques réserves dans la classe
politique
je vous propose d'écouter trois
réactions collecter tout à l'heure par
bernard pradines haut il est clair
maintenant que monsieur chirac et les
siens pratiquer une politique de coups
de théâtre
et essayent de peser sur les émotions
collectives des français en ce qui
concerne l'opération militaire en
nouvelle calédonie qui est concomitante
et qui intervient également trois jours
avant le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
elle a abouti à la libération des
gendarmes et du magistrat
c'est est un impératif absolu mais elle
se termine par 17 morts j'approuve le
gouvernement d'avoir pris cette méthode
est d'avoir fait refait obtenir force à
la loi je crois que il y a des moments
où le gouvernement doit faire face ces
doit faire front et faire respecter
l'autorité de la loi et de l'état le
gouvernement français s'est livré ce
matin à un hack de purement coloniale
c'est la politique de la canonnière et
ce qui s'est passé ce matin ne grandit
pas le lit majeur 23 gendarmes ont été
libérés mais au prix de la mort de
quinze canal
on ne peut pas considérer cela comme un
succès et cela fait surtout la
démonstration que la vida mélanésiens
n'a décidément pas le même prix que
celle d'un blanc en nouvelle calédonie
voilà je vous donne rapidement une
dernière réaction arlette laguiller
s'indigne et protestent c'est un assaut
dit elle dans le plus pur style
colonialiste je cite ces propos pour la
militante de lutte ouvrière jean marie
le pen a été entendu par jacques chirac
et par françois mitterrand à trois jours
seulement du scrutin alors que lamar
l'opération otage au liban a plus ou
moins éclipsé on l'a vu la sphère
d'ouvéa mais à terme il s'est sans doute
passé quelque chose sur les cailloux
quelque chose de j'allais dire presque
irréparable oui un seul chiffre traduit
la gravité de la situation en
nouvelle-calédonie 17 morts cette nuit +
4 morts le 22 avril dernier quatre
gendarmes assassiné par les
indépendantistes au cours de la prise
d'otages au total donc 21 morts six
militaires et 15 kanak c'est beaucoup
beaucoup trop et cet événement a été
occultée vous l'avais dit dans une
certaine mesure par la libération des
otages du liban mais il ne faut pas se
tromper
la prise d'otages le 22 avril et la
riposte musclée des autorités peuvent
avoir des conséquences dramatiques
la coexistence entre les différentes
communautés semble être aujourd'hui très
compromise il est possible qu'on
atteigne la barre à un point de non
retour
ce n'est pas un hasard si la prise
d'otage a eu lieu le 22 avril deux jours
avant le premier tour c'était une
provocation destinée à obliger les
candidats faire des concessions
ce n'est pas un hasard si l'assaut a été
donné cette nuit 3 juin avant le
deuxième tour
jacques chirac a voulu montrer sa
fermeté et sa détermination avant le
jour du scrutin
s'agit-il pour autant d'événements
ponctuels liés à la seule campagne
électorale on aurait tort de reléguer
ces deux événements au rang des
péripéties liées à une simple campagne
électorale cela n'a rien à voir avec les
accrochages avec la nervosité avec les
maux inhérents à une campagne électorale
ces événements ne seront pas oubliés et
l'homme qui sera élu dimanche quel qu'il
soit aura du mal à faire
rétablir le dialogue en nouvelle
calédonie la liste des victimes
s'allonge en effet chaque jour sur ce
caillou qui n'est plus un caillou et qui
deviennent un volcan merci paul en
france l'actualité à travers un chiffre
je vous le donne rapidement le commerce
extérieur affiche un excédent j'ai bien
dit un excédent de 1,8 milliard de
francs en mars le même commerce
extérieur avait accusé un déficit de 5,2
milliards de francs en février dernier
affaire à suivre
les télégrammes d'actualité commenté
comme chaque soir par isabelle staes
commerce extérieur excédentaire en mars
+1 8 milliards de francs contre un
déficit de 5,2 milliards en février
selon le ministère de l'économie c'est
le meilleur résultat depuis 15 mois il
s'explique surtout par une forte hausse
des exportations
manifestation des ouvriers de michelin
aujourd'hui à clermont-ferrand venus de
toute la france les bi des
établissements michelin avait rejoint
ceux de l'usiné mère les grévistes
réclament en moyenne 1500 francs en
augmentation de salaire
une série d'explosions détruit deux
usines dans le nevada un morts 200
blessés et plusieurs ouvriers portés
disparus la déflagration a été ressentie
à las vegas à 15 km de là et des usines
fabriquer du carburant pour les navettes
spatiales ou défaillance des équipements
seraient à l'origine du smooth
gigantesque incendie dans le plus haut
gratte ciel de los angeles le feu a
confirmé une partie de cette somme est
bhl de soixante deux étages faisant un
mort et une vingtaine de blessés
les pompiers ont mis plus de trois
heures pour le maîtriser le système anti
incendie de l'immeuble était en cours
d'installation voit la fin de ce journal
il était exceptionnel vous l'avez
compris mais l'effet que nous avons
développé ce soir avec l'ensemble de la
rédaction méritait amplement une édition
spéciale toute l'équipe qui m'a aidé à
préparer le journal vous remercie de
votre fidélité
dans quelques instants place au cinéma
avec coup de tête un film de